What do you think Letty?
I think I'm loving Cuba right now
Wherever you go
I go
How is that honeymoon going, Dom?
What do you want?
You are gonna work for me
Dominic Toretto
Just went rogue
You are gonna turn your back on family?
I don't know what she has got on him
But, That wasn't Dom
I'm taking you down
Toretto, you wanna play like that?
Dom!
You love me
And you are not gonna shoot me
Dominic Toretto
Just went rogue
You are gonna turn your back on family
I'm taking you down
Toretto!
You wanna play like that?
If, you are gonna catch Dom
You are gonna need a little help
You wanna tell me, Why did you just put me in a room with this criminal
You don't think that tight t-shirt is cutting off the circulation to your brain
You should get a bigger size
You guys are gonna work together
Love to
Bombs away
Holy!
They just don't give up, do they?
Ha? Damn!
Fire
Dom!
I don't wanna go swimmin'
I got you brother
YEAH!